is a new poll out from the Wall Street
Journal norc it shows that support for
traditional American values has declined
it's declined precipitously almost
across the board
this poll measured five areas patriotism
Community involvement religion having
children and money only one of those is
increased guess which one I think you
know the people still like making money
we will still support making money but
all the other ones have declined
precipitously so now we are just
worshiping Mammon here what's it say in
the Bible seek ye first money and then
all the other stuff will follow no I
don't think I don't think that's quite
what it says all of the things that make
our country great
people no longer value patriotism
religion having kids Community
involvement
just money we value